Let's go to the eight five zero area code.
Caller from eight five zero.
What's your name and where are you calling
from?
David, this is Phillip and I'm calling from
Mississippi, I've got a Florida number there.
They love my call.
What's going on?
Well, I've got two questions.
First of all, did you see the news recently
where Trump actually admitted his game plan
as far as this the Supreme Court take and
kind of taken going to the Supreme Court and
arguing against the Melling ballots and trying
to take over that way?
Yep, absolutely.
So Trump.
Trump has said he is counting on the court
system to help him in November.
He says it's to prevent it from being rigged.
Really, it's to rig it.
And the federal appeals courts could be a
part of it.
Who knows?
Depending on what happens, the Supreme Court
could be a part of it.
Absolutely.
Right.
The second thing I want to address is that
it seems, though, the Republicans, the only
way they can get ahead is through recruiting.
At least that's the kind of like what conclusion
I'm coming to.
I mean, over the last seven years, as I'm
sure you know, schools over the last seven
elections, we've only had one Republican win
by popular vote.
So this Electoral College and the gerrymander
mentoring and all the judges that recently
McConnell is picking, it seems the whole game
plan is to stay in power with the Republicans,
to stay in power just by trying to steal the
vote and oppressed the boats.
And if you look at, you know, you look at
polls and CNN and Fox News and online, everybody
plays left.
Yeah.
All the things that we won't.
All the things everybody is actually voting
for.
We're voting is easy is left leaning policies.
But we don't see that reflected in the White
House because the voting is just it's not
there, just not easy to vote.
So I believe that if we can ever start having
a conversation about making voting a national
holiday, about actually do we like Australia,
perhaps where they have a fine if you don't
vote or have the day off and just make it
easier, more accessible?
I think we could finally go in one direction.
This country is sort of back and forth ridiculous.
Stop every four to eight years and actually
get some David Pakman.
Yeah, I think that's going to happen unless
we do something with the Supreme Court, which
is kind of going to be very difficult now
at this point.
Well, mandatory voting is kind of its own
question, and I think that that's a separate
issue.
But you've beautifully pointed out that we
have a system that we you know, we talk abstractly
about checks and balances and all of this
stuff.
But we have a system that in practice allows
a center left country to be run by right wing
legislative bodies and judicial bodies because
of the things you're pointing out.
If you look at gerrymandering, you have a
structural disadvantage for Democrats when
it comes to what percentage of the vote do
they need to get in order to just have 50
percent representation?
You look at the Senate, the Senate, by giving
two senators to each state, dramatically overstates
the power of these states with very few people
that still get two senators.
And I think it was something like there were
enough you could have.
The senators representing only 17 percent
of the population decide that Trump is getting
acquitted in terms of impeachment because
of that imbalance and the fundamentally undemocratic
nature of the Senate.
You have the Electoral College, as you point
out, wherein you have a country that votes
for Democrats many times and many of those
times a Republican is still elected president.
So you've pointed out many of the ways in
which the country is not really democratically
run.
And it is a major problem.
Right now, I just don't feel like we're going
to make any consistent progress forward, no
matter what we do in the next four to eight
years, it can be undone.
It's risk repeat, which keep going back and
forth.
And it's very difficult to make this of progress
if we're not able to lead in one direction.
Well, I do think that if Joe Biden wins and
Democrats take the Senate, you could definitely
undo a bunch of the damage Trump has done
and make some progress.
But let's not put the cart before the horse.
Let's deal with November first and then see
where we are.
Right.
Thanks for taking my call, David.
All right.
Appreciate it.
Thank you so much